we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
a number of you calling in writing in
about this very question this is from
the eggman who asks it
so eloquently
hey dave i have a pretty basic question
is the city of kiev the one that used to
be called kiev yes
shalom yes shalom to the eggman uh
it is so here's uh many of you wrote to
me because yesterday during our coverage
of the russian invasion of ukraine
i was talking about kiev
and in the comments as well as an email
voicemail many of you said
sir what the hell are you talking about
isn't it kiev here's the backstory the
spell it all stems from the spelling
in english the anglicized spelling for a
very long time the capital city of
ukraine was spelled k-i-e-v
and when you look at that that very
clearly would make most english speakers
say oh it's kiev that makes sense it
spelled k-i-e-v and it's pronounced kiev
couple years ago a number of media
outlets including npr decided
uh we are going to
change the spelling and the
pronunciation to be more in line with
in ukraine the spelling was changed to k
y i v
and when you see kyv
most english speakers would see that and
they would say oh that looks like kiev
right okay so that's what happened the
idea was we've kind of anglicized it
away from what it actually is
in ukraine
let's try to match up with that more so
now it's it's a new spelling kyiv and
it's a new pronunciation keiv spell it
however you want it say it however you
want it and russia has started executing
a slow invasion of ukraine as we covered
earlier in the program so appreciate the
eggman calling in about that
and appreciate the opportunity to
clarify
on today's bonus show we are going to
talk about the history and the history
is quite extensive of why russian
president vladimir putin
is obsessed with ukraine we will also
talk about why it's ukraine and not
the ukraine okay
saying the ukraine would be like saying
well anyway i'm not even gonna get ahead
of myself okay let's we're gonna talk
about that on the bonus show we are also
going to talk about the first public
option health care plan in the u.s
which is not getting the traction that
we had hoped we're going to talk about
its details and we're going to talk
about why and then lastly if you have
filed your tax return
and it's taking longer than usual for it
to be processed etc the irs is dealing
with such a backlog
and a worker shortage that they are
actively trying to hire more people to
actually go through that backlog of tax
returns and modifications and
resubmissions etc and we will talk about
how long it is all expected to take
that's on today's bonus show sign up on
my website joinpacman.com you'll get
instant access to the bonus show also a
reminder many live events upcoming in
the next week starting thursday evening
we will be live with cpac from florida
the conservative political action
conference thursday friday saturday
sunday donald trump expected to
keynote cpac i guess on sunday afternoon
and we will be live with all of it
monday i will deliver my state of the
show address
one day before joe biden tuesday night
will deliver his state of the union
address which we will have live on
youtube twitch and facebook so i hope
you will join me for many if not all of
these live events and in the meantime
sign up at joinpakman.com to get access
to the daily bonus show
for our members only i will speak to you
then